[Aplausos]
bom dia a todos como hostil já disse eu
dei aulas no parque durante cerca de 50
anos foi mais seco a vencer mas que tem
que ser ativa pensamento errado
totalmente errado porque eu tive um
software de várias direções pensarem por
mim não foi passado a empresa já tem
sorte com as direções que passaram para
mim e passaram por mim porque obrigaram
todos os anos um jogo de série é mudar a
me adaptar seus medos
ao longo dessa caminhada e quando
chegamos ao fim do ano ou sinta montanha
e temos que os atingiram o seu primeiro
passaporte sonho
sentimos uma certa é grega ao mesmo
tempo muitas delas é uma tristeza porque
os pelos do ar que procurar outros
sonhos uma alegria
sabemos que durante um ano os
acompanhamos dessa caminhada e ajudarmos
caraças quando os jovens dizer que a
maior parte das coisas que se ensina na
escola pouca ou nenhuma utilidade também
servem para ter notas nos testes nos
exercícios só para esquecer
se pensarmos bem de uma forma simplista
e só vai a julgamento está matemática
que a escola não serve como fonte de
cultura e conhecimento é é apenas um
local onde vai indicar esta pode ser a
escola que temos não é por certo a
escola que queremos
e muito menos a escola que necessitando
então não quero não podemos ficar
parados e que alguma coisa está mal é
necessário alterar alguma coisa no dia a
dia
a mensagem professora lindo tudo e
simplesmente não está a passar e com
dizia o padre antónio vieira
o o sal não salga o terra
senão taxas algarve ou seja o professor
não tem capacidade para mostrar a
importância daquele que ensina o aluno
não está preparado para a campanha dele
para mim
qualquer destas notas negativas é
frustrante e portanto a escola é certo
que a atlantis se eu pensar que embora
as teses acompanhou o fundo manteve como
que parado no tempo já vem desde os
primórdios do século 20 alguns até
anteriores que mente um seleto desde a
infância são fomentados pela e para as
novas tecnologias se pensarmos bem
salvaguardando algumas experiências
pedagógicas que ocorre no número
restrito de escolas que acontece na
maioria das restantes continuam sentados
frente um professor do manual aberto à
sua frente
ora numa era em que os jovens têm a sua
ao alcance de um simples clique
toda e qualquer inflexão boa parque
caíram em termos pro vezes como se
fossem setako vizinho não pensante
programa encher com doses de tega que
não cultiva que forma dupla com o flu
está e mesmo ultrapassada
quer dizer deviam estar orientados para
a pesquisa para o trabalho organizado
para prometer partilha de conhecimento
continuamos ela e para a mobilização
o facebook tista certo conceito que
muitas vezes e os meios querem
terrorismo disseram a um programa
o programa traça metas objetivos o
programa não em que o caminho
isso é da responsabilidade do prof
acontece que não a lan que a forma de
ensinar e muito menos forma é aprender
então ao já pepe de cadu
em vez de procurar resgatar horizonte e
ter espírito livre para pensar o seu
próprio caminho
e os nossos objetivos
o exemplo é que talvez ao que são os
grandes centros grande certo estão
aqueles que ambicionam criatividade e
mesmo em san juan o outro ingrediente
que pioram paladar uma apresentação
cuidada hora sempre procurando ensinar
algo sim ativos e aumentar a confiança
mesmo reforma de escola para escola e
turma a turma um denominador comum o
controlo e o comando da aula pertencem
os alunos não poderão atingir o objetivo
que é mais grave
hoje o jovem faz parte das escolas a
escola é possível grande responsável
amanhã
por lá a prova cada vez mais em
financiamento a capacidade de inovar ser
diferente ser dinâmico em pintosa ser
exigente consigo próprio e quer paz
tomar decisões justas responsável
mas para que isso aconteça é necessário
incentivar o jovem de hoje lamento
ganhar asas e voar
olhando para a sua educação não como uma
via para obter um emprego mas sim como
forma de conhecer um mundo em que vive e
no qual se integra isso as escolas não
podem mais ser montou um corpos e
cristelo isso aumenta a chance delas
abertas em que se ensina a utilizar e
esquecer onde não científica se associe
uma sólida formação humana o respeito ao
próximo e cidadania plena na sociedade
embora os problemas da equipe
mas é outro nós não podemos fazer o
mesmo
não podemos deixar que as coisas corram
e dizer que o salvas não estão
interessados nos tops com isso mesmo sem
todas as épocas os ovos jovem está em
sua vivência diária tem no seu mundo e
nós é que temos que entrar no deus que o
mundo deus é o nosso mundo é isso que é
necessário isso e penso que a escola que
necessitamos deveria ter não é fechada
para que todos pudessem ler e editar o
livro do conformismo o teu espírito
livre pensar em evoluir e criar um
legado tron o legado
[Aplausos]